thank you Ted game changing
opportunities just landed in the hands
of 150 local businesses hand selected
for the Super Bowl business connect
program so now they are one step closer
to working with the big game itself and
several other events that support it 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthews shows us
their new potential
we're just under 300 days away from
Super Bowl 58 bringing 65 000 Spectators
just to a legion Stadium alone and
thousands more across the valley all for
a week full of events local businesses
now have a better chance of benefiting
from
afraid to get down and dirty like you
want to get wood carpet
don't use Steam on that he owns wet low
maintenance a team of just 22 employees
that's queened Las Vegas carpets floors
walls and windows for over two decades
and next year he's looking at a big
client we're going to get a lot more
workers if you're looking at the Super
Bowl you're looking at problem 150
people is 200 people just to clean that
Stadium right there
he's one of a select few chosen this
week for the Las Vegas Super Bowl
business connect program 150 Las Vegas
businesses chosen by the host committee
across nearly 30 different disciplines
each owned at least 51 percent by a
person in a minority group and they're
going to be introduced to buyers and
procurement Representatives it's step
one to work the Super Bowl says host
committee Chief Community engagement
officer Maisha Boyce so people that are
in business connect their information is
in the database we are absolutely
combing that database on a regular basis
150 businesses now put in a resource
guide that's given to NFL vendors who
are looking for local suppliers whether
for the big game the parties leading up
to the game
or for this business the cleanup after
it's something very very huge this
program is an open door because now they
have a pool they say okay we've seen
what little man would give them a call
NFL vendors are not required to pick
from this resource guide for their
subcontracting needs but the host
committee adds that this guide lives
beyond the Super Bowl it's used almost
like a recommendation list for major
sporting teams hotels and events